let's talk a little bit about what's
going on in New York City there's this
thing called stop and frisk in New York
City its controversial because it's
disproportionately applied to black and
Latino people and this is where police
can decide to basically stop people
frisk them and they're looking for guns
or drugs and there's been a pretty
significant change made to the NYPD's
attitude toward stop and frisk starting
just under a month from now NYPD
officers are going to be issuing
receipts to anyone that they stop but
don't arrest and they will be offering a
reason why they did this officers will
also have to fill in their badge number
and provide contact information for the
civilian review board this is coming out
of a lawsuit called Floyd versus the
city of New York where a judge found
that yes NYPD is unfairly targeting
minorities for stop and frisk there are
some reform advocates who say the
writing of the badge number is a concern
because officers can just sort of
scribble it and you'll never really know
who it was so there were actually some
groups Louis who wanted a card sort of
like a business card to be given out
which would make it so that bad
handwriting wouldn't prevent you from
knowing who exactly frisk you yeah you
don't need to do that uh-uh make sure
just make sure it's legible and you have
a cell phone tell them I'm going to take
a picture of your badge I'm going to
take a picture of your face and uh well
it's New York so the police officers
might be up for that but uh it's still
worth a shot and uh I'm just picturing
it now they they tell you yet you know
we stopped you in frist you today
because you're black well that is not
one of the boxes you can check on the
receipt Rachel you'll be that the
officers will have categories and they
can say that they were acting as a
lookout but that they believe that the
individual they stopped and frisked may
have been acting as a lookout that they
may have been engaging in a drug
transaction and that they matched a
specific suspect description that they
were looking for oh boy these are very
very vague and you can basically this I
don't think will change how easily it is
to stop and frisk someone but ideally if
their handwriting is
good enough will allow us to identify
trends of particular officers who may be
problematic well there's always going to
be a way to kind of circumvent the truth
if you're looking at the body cams and
all of the officers who are saying oh oh
it got dislodged and and it didn't
record everything I'm so sorry it's not
going to happen again so how is this
going to be different I think the
difference would be that it at least
makes it possible to have accountability
obviously if you switch off the body
camera the accountability goes away if
you scribble the badge number in a way
that's not legible or if you just check
off you thought maybe somebody was
acting as a lookout I get Jason how you
can always take advantage of the system
but i still believe is better to have
something than nothing yeah I agree so
something else that I think is kind of
relevant here's I heard a story about
how there's this it's similar to
whatsapp and there's app were kind of
neighbors are kind of you know learning
each other to activity and actually had
a it's the first social media that's
institute a filter on their social media
so if you report a crime in your
neighborhood you can't just say oh
there's a black guy out there you
actually have to fill in you know what
his shoes look like what was he wearing
to kind of you know slightly circumvent
the racism and kind of note bigotry
surrounding it I i have this is
something we should do a bigger story on
but I recently actually was there when
someone called the police and there was
a question asked about the race anyway
it's it's an interesting story not a
story for today but let's agree to talk
about it soon and I want to get
everybody's thoughts on